Trascrizione: Alessio Politi
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Un bellissimo paesaggio.
Secondo me è, anche,
uno straordinario paesaggio.
Lì nel mezzo, c'è un'azienda agricola.
Con il mio lavoro di agronomo ed enologo
mi capita di visitare, letteralmente
ogni giorno, in giro per il mondo,
tantissime aziende agricole diverse.
C'è una cosa semplice, elementare
che tutte le aziende agricole
hanno in comune:
è il suolo.
E c'è qualcosa, nel suolo,
che da tanti anni a me ha sempre
affascinato e mi ha appassionato.
È il fatto che il suolo
può, letteralmente, avere una memoria,
e un suolo può essere vivo.
Quando parliamo di memoria,
noi abbiamo le idee chiare.
Noi sappiamo cos'è la memoria.
Io so che mi chiamo Adriano,
questa mattina mi sono ricordato
che dovevo venire al TED per conoscervi.
E sappiamo anche dare una definizione:
possiamo definirla
come una funzione psichica
di riprodurre nella mente
un'esperienza passata.
E sappiamo anche, molto banalmente,
dove andare a collocare la memoria:
nel nostro cervello.
Ed è la stessa cosa
anche per quanto riguarda
i nostri amici animali.
Quindi la memoria è nel nostro cervello,
dove guarda caso
ha anche sede l'intelligenza.
Se però cominciamo a domandarci
dov'è il cervello delle piante,
dov'è l'intelligenza delle piante,
cominciamo ad avere un po’ di difficoltà.
Perché penso che nessuno di voi
abbia mai incontrato
un cervello in una pianta.
Non l'ho incontrato
nemmeno io, da agronomo.
Per fortuna, per rispondere
a questa domanda
ci aiutano gli scienziati
che si occupano di neurobiologia vegetale.
Ci sono diverse università del mondo
che studiano le interazioni
nella pianta e tra piante,
e ci insegnano che la maggior parte
dell'intelligenza delle piante,
guarda caso,
è collocata nelle radici,
che stanno nel suolo.
È lì che dobbiamo andare a ricercare
tutti i fenomeni legati all'intelligenza
e alla memoria delle piante:
nel suolo.
Quindi cominciamo un po’
ad avvicinarci a questo suolo.
Il suolo -
qui sotto questa chiesa c’è del suolo,
le mie mani stanno tenendo in mano
un pezzo di suolo.
Però che cos'è?
Di cosa è fatto il suolo?
Potremmo scoprire molto facilmente
che un suolo è fatto,
per la stragrande maggioranza,
di una sostanza inorganica minerale,
un insieme molto variabile
di sabbia, roccia, limo, argilla;
e solamente una piccola parte,
che va dall'uno al cinque percento,
è fatto di sostanza organica.
Che è un qualcosa che noi conosciamo già
perché l'abbiamo già sentita
nominare come "humus".
Quindi questa è la parte
organica del suolo.
All'interno di questa sostanza organica
possiamo invece andare a trovare
la parte "viva" del suolo.
E quando parliamo di un suolo vivo,
vuol dire che è pieno di batteri,
funghi, insetti, lombrichi, protozoi.
Quella che è la comunità di un suolo.
Quindi, vedete, un suolo
può essere anche vivo, e vivente,
quando è ricco
di queste simpatiche creature.
Che hanno una faccia
altrettanto simpatica,
perché se andiamo a vedere
che faccia ha la comunità di un suolo,
hanno queste facce.
E non penso che nessuno di voi
li abbia mai incontrati
nemmeno camminando, oggi, arrivando qui.
Perché molto banalmente, lo sappiamo,
abbiamo bisogno
di un grande ingrandimento.
Abbiamo bisogno di un microscopio
per andare a capire come sono fatti.
E quando abbiamo un microscopio,
possiamo scoprire
qualcosa di davvero interessante.
Come, per esempio,
che in un grammo di terreno -
un grammo è qualcosa che sta
tra il mio pollice il mio indice;
in questo spazio possiamo trovare,
in un grammo solamente,
dai 100 ai 1000 milioni di batteri
e quasi un milione di funghi,
e molte altre creature.
Quindi un suolo: è vivo; può essere vivo;
quando è vivo ha una comunità
particolarmente numerosa.
E guardate, questa comunità
la possiamo anche pesare.
Se noi prendiamo 10.000 metri quadrati -
è qualcosa che assomiglia
a un campo da calcio -
in quel campo da calcio, se li pesiamo,
la comunità del suolo
sono duemila chili di batteri,
sono seimila chili di funghi
e tante altre entità:
nematodi, radici e quant'altro.
Quindi un suolo può essere
letteralmente vivo:
c'è la sostanza organica.
Possiamo misurare il peso e il numero
della comunità vivente di un suolo.
Bene, abbiamo imparato
che esiste la sostanza organica;
ma che effetto ha, poi,
la sostanza organica?
Per capirlo, userò
questo esperimento molto semplice,
dell'Università del Maryland,
però molto efficace -
almeno, a me ha molto colpito -
dove è stata presa
la stessa quantità di suolo,
in questi due bicchieri.
Di un suolo che ha l'un percento
e il tre percento di sostanza organica:
poca sostanza organica
e tanta sostanza organica.
Tutto il resto è uguale.
A prima vista direi che si somigliano,
potremmo far finta
di vedere davvero molto poco.
La cosa interessante è che se aggiungiamo
la stessa quantità di acqua
in questi due suoli,
scopriamo questo:
scopriamo che dove c'è sostanza organica
il suolo ha capacità
di assorbire tantissima acqua;
dove c'è poca sostanza organica,
il suolo non ha capacità
di assorbire sostanza organica.
Pensate che la cosa
non ci riguardi da vicino?
Se volete, vi spiego cosa significa questo
in maniera molto molto semplice:
questo significa alluvioni,
inondazioni, frane.
Questo è una delle grandi spiegazioni
dei disastri ambientali.
Un suolo che non collabora,
e che non ha sostanza organica,
crea degli autentici disastri.
Quindi direi che forse
ci è venuta voglia di capire
come questa sostanza organica
entri nell'agricoltura,
perché ci sono diversi modi
di fare agricoltura.
Io vi parlo di circa tre modi
di fare agricoltura: i più famosi.
C'è un modo che si chiama
"agricoltura convenzionale", o integrata,
e che non si occupa di sostanza organica.
Prevede l'uso di sostanze di sintesi
che interferiscono
nella quantità e nella qualità
di quella comunità vivente
che abbiamo chiamato sostanza organica.
Quindi erosioni, e problemi
molto molto elevati.
Per quanto riguarda il suolo,
e non solamente:
anche per quanto riguarda noi.
Abbiamo poi l'agricoltura biologica:
è un'agricoltura che prevede
che non si usino queste sostanze
e queste tecniche
che alterano la vita di un suolo.
C'è poi l'agricoltura biodinamica,
quella con la quale
io lavoro da diversi anni
e nella quale c'è un'autentica ossessione.
Questa ossessione, guarda caso,
si chiama sostanza organica.
Usiamo le migliori tecniche possibili
per prenderci cura
della comunità vivente del suolo,
perché pensiamo che sia fondamentale
per fare un'ottima agricoltura.
Vediamo in che modo, però,
possiamo di nuovo misurare
questi tipi diversi di agricoltura.
È così vero che
diversi tipi di agricoltura
possono incidere così tanto
in un suolo, nell'agricoltura?
Andiamo in Svizzera dove c'è il Fibl,
che è il più grande istituto di ricerca
per quanto riguarda
i diversi tipi di agricoltura.
In pochi metri di differenza, di distanza,
due tipi di agricoltura -
la convenzionale, la biodinamica -
vengono messe a confronto,
Non abbiamo bisogno
di essere agronomi. o scienziati,
per capire che questo suolo non funziona:
si compatta, perde acqua.
ci sono poche piante e crescono male.
Dall'altra parte, abbiamo un suolo
che sta collaborando,
sta producendo tante piante
e si stanno sviluppando bene.
E guardate che questa storia
si ripete ogni volta allo stesso modo.
Se andiamo in Veneto in un vigneto,
o se andiamo in Sudafrica -
qui siamo in Veneto -
vedete [che] un suolo che funziona:
è un suolo poroso, scuro, che collabora:
è un suolo con sostanza organica.
Ecco, allora, dov'è
la memoria di un suolo:
è proprio qui.
È una scoperta molto più semplice
di quello che pensavate.
Perché un suolo può essere intelligente,
ma non ha la coscienza,
quindi non dimentica mai.
È "costretto" ad avere memoria:
e qual è la memoria?
Lui colleziona tutti gli effetti
dell'attività che l'uomo produce
nei suoi confronti.
Se usiamo un tipo di agricoltura,
si ricorderà del modo
in cui è stato trattato;
e se usiamo un altro tipo
di agricoltura, come in questo caso,
be', questa è la memoria di un suolo:
si ricorda del modo
in cui è stato trattato,
e di conseguenza agisce.
E vedete che la cosa
ha un impatto molto forte
su quelle che sono
le piante che coltiviamo.
Possiamo comparare, anche,
agricoltura biologica
e agricoltura biodinamica:
radici più profonde, ramificate;
una pianta più sana, più salutare.
Quindi forse possiamo davvero
far funzionare un suolo
in un modo diverso.
Vi mostro quali sono le tecniche
che usiamo in agricoltura biodinamica
per far funzionare bene un suolo,
quindi in che modo ci occupiamo
della sostanza organica.
Alcuni esempi:
la monocoltura distrugge
la sostanza organica,
motivo per cui cerchiamo di far convivere
più colture possibili,
ovviamente sempre in un modo
economicamente sostenibile.
Qui siamo in Liguria, in riva al mare,
questi vigneti sono circondati
da orti e da frutteti.
Quindi la biodiversità,
la monocoltura non funziona.
Andiamo in montagna:
possiamo verificare la stessa cosa,
siamo in Trentino.
In un vigneto, in mezzo a un vigneto
vengono coltivate queste verdure
per aumentare la biodiversità
e aumentare la sostanza organica.
Cosa ci fanno queste oche
in un vigneto in Sardegna?
Queste oche mangiano l'erba
e rendono inutile
il passaggio di un trattore,
che in questo caso calpesterebbe
e produrrebbe emissioni e CO2;
e facendolo,
rilasciano nel suolo gli escrementi
che sono, di nuovo,
cibo e sostanza organica per il suolo.
Questo è un esempio
di un organismo agricolo che funziona.
Usiamo dei preparati
biodinamici, e specifici,
che anche questi contribuiscono
in modo fondamentale
ad aumentare la quantità
e la qualità della sostanza organica.
Di nuovo, la comunità vivente,
che abbiamo visto prima, del suolo.
Il compostaggio:
tanti di voi, magari,
hanno un piccolo composter a casa.
E questo è un qualcosa di molto simile:
semplicemente molto più grande,
sviluppato in modo più professionale.
Ma il compostaggio non è altro
che un recupero di tutte quelle sostanze
che vengono prodotte
in un'azienda agricola
e non vengono utilizzate
per la produzione del prodotto vendibile.
E quindi, in questo modo, trattati,
tutti questi residui vegetali e animali
riproducono di nuovo del concime
che è di nuovo cibo per la terra.
Quindi la terra va nutrita,
e vedete quanti modi diversi
abbiamo per farlo.
Questo è un altro modo,
si chiama sovescio.
Ed è un modo bellissimo
per incrementare, anche,
la biodiversità di un'azienda agricola:
seminiamo delle specifiche
essenze botaniche
tra i filari di un vigneto,
tra i filari di un frutteto,
nelle rotazioni;
e a un certo momento, queste le tagliamo
e vengono ridate al suolo
come autentico cibo:
per la terra e, di nuovo,
per quella comunità
che abbiamo visto prima.
L'Agricoltura biodinamica
deriva dall'antroposofia,
dove il nome stesso ci dice
che c'è un uomo al centro.
È un tipo di agricoltura
nella quale ci prendiamo davvero cura
di noi umani, delle interazioni,
delle collaborazioni e della solidarietà.
Ed è un fatto fondamentale
perché caratterizza davvero tanto
questo tipo di agricoltura.
Come vedete, fino ad ora abbiamo parlato
di agricoltura, agricoltori, agronomia.
Potreste ancora pensare
di non essere chiamati in causa,
in tutto quello che vi sto dicendo.
Forse, [pensate che] la memoria del suolo
sia una cosa lontana da voi,
e che non vi interessi.
Vediamo se riesco
a convincervi un po’ di più.
Questo è un pane, lo conosciamo:
è un chilo di pane.
Vi siete mai posti la domanda
di quanta terra è necessaria
per coltivare la farina occorrente
per fabbricare, per produrre questo pane?
Sono circa nove metri quadrati:
è una superficie che, la vedete,
sta attorno a me con un pane al centro.
Quando allora compriamo un pane
la cui farina è derivata
dall'agricoltura biodinamica
noi ci rendiamo responsabili
della salute di quel suolo.
Quindi è una cosa che ci riguarda tutti
da molto, molto vicino.
Vedete come la consapevolezza
di un gesto alimentare
ci connette subito
con il lavoro dell'agricoltore
e entriamo anche noi in un grande cerchio,
nel quale siamo responsabili.
Siamo a Lucca, terra di olio e di pane;
e potremmo immaginare
che tutti qui dentro, che siamo 450,
ci possiamo fare una bella fettunta,
una fetta di pane con l'olio.
Beh se misurassi il terreno necessario
per produrre l'olio e il pane
per queste 450 fettunte,
con un semplicissimo gesto noi salveremmo,
e cominceremmo a far funzionare,
un suolo di 90 metri quadrati,
un appartamento intero.
E potremmo continuare
con tantissimi esempi.
Un bel piatto di pasta
con un bicchiere di vino,
una singola azione,
ci permetterebbe di salvare
quasi un metro quadrato di suolo.
Quindi vedete
come la responsabilità di ognuno di noi
comincia ad avvicinarsi alla terra,
anche se non ci muoviamo da qui.
E allora cominciamo a pensare in grande,
a pensare che magari cinque persone,
per un anno intero,
decidano di alimentarsi con prodotti
provenienti dall'agricoltura biodinamica.
E potremmo scoprire
qualcosa di interessante:
potremmo salvare una superficie di suolo
di circa 10.000 metri quadrati,
di nuovo il campo di calcio di prima.
Guardatelo, è ritornato.
E se ci piace di più,
questa è la superficie che, più o meno,
copre il pavimento del Duomo di Firenze.
Cinque persone, semplicemente in un anno,
guardate che superficie enorme
possono salvare di suolo.
Un suolo che quindi collabora,
un suolo che non si erode,
un suolo che assorbe acqua,
un suolo che tutela tutta quella che è
la comunità vivente del suolo.
Come?
Mangiando prodotti provenienti
da un'agricoltura attenta,
che in questo caso si chiama
"agricoltura biodinamica".
Ecco allora che possiamo ritornare
all'inizio del nostro viaggio.
Questa è un'azienda agricola
di 1.000 ettari,
non è una piccola azienda agricola.
Quindi ora è un po'
il tempo delle good news,
quelle che vorrei darvi.
E perché sono delle good news?
Perché questa è una grande
azienda agricola -
e non è la sola, ce ne sono tante
di grandi e piccole
che incontro nel mio lavoro
in giro per il mondo -
e che hanno deciso di adottare
un tipo di agricoltura
che collabori con il suolo:
l'agricoltura biodinamica.
Però capite che tutti questi
singoli agricoltori,
o queste comunità di agricoltori,
non possano davvero fare molto da soli.
Hanno bisogno della nostra collaborazione,
hanno bisogno della nostra consapevolezza.
Ma ora lo sapete.
Ora sapete che ognuno di voi,
quando decide di mangiare qualcosa,
collabora in modo molto, molto attivo
a quella che è la salute di un suolo.
Quindi vedete che la memoria del suolo
ci riguarda davvero molto da vicino,
perché il suolo ha bisogno di noi,
il suolo ha bisogno di essere vivo,
il suolo ha bisogno di sviluppare
la migliore memoria possibile.
Senza se e senza ma.
(Applausi)
Grazie.